celina it's lovely to see you here today
at collector mania there's so much
excitement around arrow what a fantastic
finale with Deathstroke and Oliver
fighting in your character's name what
do you think she would have made of that
it's fantastic I think the action of the
last episode has definitely not let
anybody down it is as good as the
beginning of the season like I think
arrows done really well because it
hasn't gone downhill with time it's only
gotten better and better and I think the
writers did a fantastic shot job yeah
now of course we know your character
sadly not in this world anymore but it
is a world were dead doesn't necessarily
mean dead isn't it because he will have
superpowers so how likely are we to see
your character come back for season 3 I
couldn't tell you if I told you that I'd
have to kill you you know now I can't I
can't give away what's going to happen
for season 3 but I must say the writers
have done such an incredible job of
constantly surprising the audience so
how much would you like to come back and
if you could come back what would you
like to see your character doing in
future for me as an actress like I just
want to play many different shades of
the character and her role so I think
that I've been really lucky so far to be
able to play such different aspects of
her which I think every person has like
the demon the hero so yeah I just
honestly like I just want to bring the
the writers and the creators vision to
this screen and I'm happy to take on
whatever challenge they throw me now
it's got a great cast of characters both
the actors and their characters on
screen who would you like to have spend
more screen time with in the show and
who would you like to have a faceoff
with I would love to have more screen
time with Emily BETT Rickards who plays
felicity who would I like to face off
with that's it that's a cool one you
know who I really like Katrina law plays
Nyssa and she's such a sweetheart by the
way in person but she's a really good
fighter and I would love to face off
with her
yeah I'd love to see that we've already
heard that we were getting some people
back for season three John Barrowman
spinner nails is becoming a season
regular what do you think about that
what do you think he'll bring to series
three John Barrowman is such an
incredible actor he has so much charisma
I'm sure the Barrowman fans are going
absolutely insane that he's going to be
back for arrow yeah we're just we're
really happy to have him back
I think we've missed him for season two
and and it's awesome that they're
bringing him back and of course you've
got a spinoff from arrow now as well
I'll have a read the flash what do you
think about that isn't Grant Gustin so
hot I think that you know he is a great
actor and he's going to play Barry Allen
so well I love that you know he can play
the geeky guy but also the here I just I
cannot wait to watch flash would you
like to see your character make a little
move sideways into the flash world and
what would you like to see I do that
would be really cool actually I don't
know if that's gonna happen but yeah
that'd be really cool I'd love to have
more scenes with them Barry that would
be awesome
and of course loads excitement around
the DC world isn't that and which
characters would you like to see brought
into arrow or even the flash and also
what do you think of the whole world of
the Justice League movie coming up
because a lot of people would like you
know arrow characters like Stephen Amell
and yourself to be in that Justice
League movie um I think that you know
right now there's definitely a trend of
DC Comics and Marvel Comics going to the
theaters I think you know I think it
fans would be so happy to see Justice
League movie and in terms of characters
I'd love to see like Ra's al Ghul come
in and League of Assassins
so yeah would you like to kind of be
besides that you know Wendy woman in
maybe a Batman vs Superman movies role
that would be pretty cool
that would definitely be pretty cool
there's actually so much that you know
people can do with the DC comic so I
just yeah I look forward to seeing how
they kind of expand their
their universe you know and what do you
think all we've just seen very recently
a little peek of Ben Affleck in his bat
suit and with his Batmobile as well what
do you think about Ben Affleck as Batman
and what do you think he'll bring to the
par hearts heart yeah I look forward to
seeing that I really do and if you could
have been any other character in arrow
who would you like to be if you could
swap characters for a day no I don't
want to talk I'm pretty happy with shado
I think that having such a strong female
character on arrow which is great like
we have the Black Canary
we have shadow but also the fact that
she is Oliver Queen sensei is just I
mean I couldn't ask for better I must
say I'm a very lucky girl to work
alongside of Steven as well as Monday I
mean they're both really really good
people and very good looking and very
professional actors it's fun it's really
fun I've learned a lot from them from
both of them and they've really helped
me develop my character as well from
season 1 to season 2 finally how much of
a comic book fan were you before you
became part of that world of era and how
much kind of boning up researcher did
you have to do I did I did some research
definitely on shadow I mean in the comic
book she's you know she actually shoots
a Yumi and not American flat Bo and you
know her character was Japanese or a lot
of differences I did do my research to
get to know her better especially in the
audition phase and then after that it
was a matter of talking to the writers
to to UM develop her character further
yeah it's been lovely to speak to you
today Selina thanks very much for your
time
nice to meet you guys too
you